[Music]
so you sent me this silly thing this
morning and i watched it and it's just
like oh my god these people okay so what
is this
okay so
there's a thing called instagram if
you're unaware
and
it's my social media of choice i don't
really do twitter i don't really do
facebook i just i do love instagram so i
i look at i look at instagram okay so
i'm in i'm in my stuff so people will
send me clips that are on instagram from
like funny stuff to you know even their
own journey and i see a lot of it
because i do try to go through it so
this one clip has been sent to me i'm
not kidding probably 10 times from 10
random people over the world that are
just like can you believe this guy can
you you know this this this and i kept
seeing it come up and so
i had i clicked on i was like oh man
number one it's terrible advice i think
it came originally maybe it was a tick
tock video but it's an instagram reel of
how we saw it like a tick tock video and
because there's ev everyone's a
financial expert on social media today
right and with investing they all know
what they're going to do and how to how
you make money quick and all this stuff
you know you got it you got to do all
this stuff so so here's a video it was a
and it's a father-daughter which you'll
see
and i just thought well here's a
father-daughter and i don't want to harp
on them
i want to harp on the situation i do i
know you do okay let's let's let's play
the play the instagram reel
this is my daughter maddie
we are at a car dealership right now and
she's about to buy her first car tell me
how you're buying your first car this
morning i went to the bank i got my
first car loan i qualified for 15 000.
at what interest rate
percent with the money that i have saved
up i have seven thousand dollars in cash
i'm going to invest that into an airbnb
property and get 14
interest back so that way i can use that
money to pay off my car length so
basically kind of getting a car for free
wait maddie can you explain that one
more time a little more simply yeah so
it cost me three cents to borrow a
dollar from the bank and then i go and
take that dollar now my dollar and i
give to someone for 14 cents and then so
14 minus three eleven so i keep the
difference in the middle what's that
called arbitrage boom you buy
assets that then cash flow and pay
for your stock
i mean he's so proud well i mean he's so
slimy there's there's a few things you
need to take a shower after watching
that oh my gosh
it just drips in arrogance
well there's a lot there's a lot of
things about this number one i really
don't feel like you can get an interest
rate i i don't think you can get a lot
she's how old was she she's 15 she
cannot get a bank loan no so he
co-signed which probably helped get a
lower interest rate and then what i
don't understand is the eleven thousand
dollars in an airbnb property you can't
buy an airbnb property for eleven
thousand dollars either you could invest
in it with a bunch of partners
into an airbnb property and that's
assuming the airbnb property stays
rented and the local city council
doesn't pass a law against airbnbs in
which case your little butt would be
broke at 15 years old because your
father's a [ __ ]
oh my god
was i unclear no
i was like we're not going to harp on
the people
but but speak to the notion though
because that stuff is everywhere that
you get you you borrow this you take
that percentage and that difference and
you go get that asset and then this and
that and you play this game full
disclosure i had you on stage at 15
years old okay oh what a slimy so full
disclosure
so full disclosure i i have nothing
the difference the difference is the
advice that we were giving was not so
bad
and we were not as slimy or
condescending i don't think oh my god
it's called arbitrage okay which is
greek for i'm stupid oh my god
oh okay but talk about the that notion
though because that well it's the set of
assumptions the set of assumptions you
have to go through for all that crap to
be true are absolutely ludicrous okay
number one you have never met a
millionaire we studied 10 167 of them
zero of them precisely zero said i
borrowed money on my car
and arbitraged it into being a
millionaire
zero real millionaires do that zero
zero none
i borrowed money on my car and put
eleven thousand dollars into an airbnb
when i was fifteen
with all of my business acumen on
display because she didn't even know
what the interest rate was go back and
watch the clip again she's well i i i
well and they had to edit it what was it
oh three and a half well tell them again
matt tell him again darling what you did
oh
she don't even know what she did
she really didn't
she was a little parrot
so you know
number one no but the the whole concept
of i'm gonna borrow money
on assets listen you duber cars go down
in value yes you can call them an asset
if you want but they're not much of an
asset and if you leverage your car to
get rich you might never get there
this is because mathematically is that's
true but also the spirit behind it well
mathematically it's
you are not measuring risk
and you're making a set of assumptions
that a 13 year old 15 year old can
borrow money at three and a half percent
they can't you can't contract unless
you're a legal adult and borrowing money
is a contract in any state in the united
states okay that's why a kid can't have
a mutual fund you have to have a
custodial account that's why a kid can't
have a savings account or a checking
account you have to have a parent on
there as a custodian because kids can't
contract they can't buy beer and they
can't borrow money from a car dealer
god
um so now then once you've done all that
though let's just pretend you weren't a
kid yeah and you went and really
borrowed money at three and a half
percent here's the thing you have to
follow
factual causation
find people who have actually done
your theory
find me one
who 15 years later using that type of
system
is a millionaire or greater you can't
find them because they're not there
they're not there okay that's a word let
me ask you this question
uh because there is again there's this
this thing that is floating around in
the culture there really is though
that's called stupidity i know i bet let
me just present the stupidity and then
you can you can debunk it because you're
really great at that right now okay
that um you know if you just like want
to kind of be like yeah maybe you can
just like i'm like you can have some
some wealth and you just that that's
what investing does and it's more but if
you really want to become like super
wealthy
you you you have to you know be in real
you have to do these these things these
jump through hoops and you're and you're
doing math that that most people can't
grasp and understand because you're
playing the game i mean this is a
perfect example like the way he's uh
it's called arbitrage the way he's
explaining it makes it feel like oh
there's something i'm missing
and in order to build wealth and to
become rich there's other systems that i
don't know about
that can cause me to become rich
is there a level of that 30 years ago
when i came on the air
the secrets of the rich
were out there then
everybody's got a book seek seven
secrets to getting rich here's the
problem
it's not a secret
there's not a magic sauce there's not a
magic sauce
mcdonald's special sauce is basically
thousand island there is no special
sauce okay there's not any that's it i
mean you really you gotta live on less
than you make you have to invest
steadily over a long period of time and
there is no like i learned a new word
and that made me wealthy
if you know maybe compound interest
would be close okay but compound
interest works over time with time and
consistency so maybe that's a new word
for him and he learns that word and
that's a good word but you you know the
the people that say there's a short
they're looking for a shortcut i mean
that's what it is that's what i'm saying
and they're brilliant they're brilliant
they know things because they're on
tick-tock and they know oh god shoot me
um
i just i'm having trouble finding
intelligent life on tick-tock we're
going to have to get on tick-tock not on
tick-tock that's not on my phone i don't
know i just i can't i don't want it on
my phone but i guess we're going to have
to
we're going to have to put content on
there to just
mess with this
we're putting money out there we're
putting money out there or advice out
there but kill him
what's happening this is the ramsey show